- Hey, y'all we've got
an exciting announcement.
Spectrum is now a game.
That's right, we've heard your cry.
We've just launched our Kickstarter.
So please go and support it now.
We hope you love it.
(upbeat music)
- I love bi men, I'm very
attracted to trans men
but that would still make me gay though
'cause they're all-
- That just means you're super gay.
(all laughing)
(upbeat music begins)
This remind at the marker game.
Like when trivia with like the
marker in like seventh grade.
- [Interviewer] Who is most
likely to pull a prank?
- Really?
- You did, you ripped up a donut.
- But that's only because he
pulled so many pranks on me
that I was getting him back.
- Oh.
- Throughout the seasons,
I think it's you.
- I'm like the least.
- Maybe him and I have
have a better relationship
and he likes to pull pranks-
- You ripped off my toenail.
- Not to be a narcissist,
but what about me?
- When do you ever
pull the prank?
- What about you?
- I'm constantly, like
whenever we're really tired
and it's been like a 12 hour day.
I'm like, "Oh, I just found
out we have another six hours."
and then you guys all get
into like a big huff about it.
- [Jonathan] You literally
like never made that joke.
- [Interviewer] Who is more likely
to win America's Next Top Model?
- Oh.
- [Interviewer] Three, two, one.
- Sorry, also me.
(Bobby laughing)
Yeah.
- He has the look down.
- It's true.
- Tan?
She's seen every episode.
- Get your (beep) over here.
(Bobby laughs)
- I just wanted to become-
- Get your (beep) over here right now.
- We don't want any fighting.
We're all standing in this lane.
- You know anything to
do with Top Model is his.
(all talking at once)
- Thank you for your participation.
- [Interviewer] Who is more
likely to tell it like it is?
- Oh, oh, oh.
- [Interviewer] Three, two, one, .
- Oh (beep) (beep) (beep).
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I just, I'm very British.
(all laugh)
- [Interviewer] Who is
more likely to send you
a thoughtful message or gift just because?
- That's cute Jackie, thanks baby.
- [Jonathan] You're really the only one
who does nice stuff for me.
- Oh.
- (beep) you.
(all laugh)
- Karamo actually just
randomly sends me messages.
- Antoni will often
send gifts very sweetly.
- And he took you on that vacation.
- And he took me to vacation to Mexico.
- [Interviewer] Who is more likely
to get stopped on the street.
- Well, it's really Tan, but
I'm gonna say Antoni only
because his reaction's the funniest.
He pretends like he doesn't see you.
- I get overwhelmed.
- Pretend, pretend to see me.
I'm Antoni and you be like
someone getting excited.
- Oh my god, Antoni, Antoni.
Hey Antoni, Antoni, Antoni!
See me, love me, love me, see me!
(Bobby laughing)
I love you.
- I'm out, goodbye, thank you.
This was so much fun.
- He used to get really nervous.
He used to get really really nervous.
- I get severe social anxiety
and I would just get really overwhelmed
and I'd get like severe
palpitations and I sweat like crazy.
- [Interviewer] Being on
Queer Eye was my dream.
Three, two, one, go.
- Once I heard about that audition, honey.
- (Bobby) Well, I still-
- I was ready.
- Remember, I almost didn't
show up to the auditions
'cause I had a trip planned to Spain
and I was like there's no
way I'm gonna get this.
I'm just gonna go to Spain.
- I've still never seen the American,
I've never seen the American-
- What?
- [Jonathan] Oh my god really?
- Yeah.
I still remember exactly where I was.
I was at 3 Gold St.
- [Interviewer] Bobby,
what were your thoughts
when you watched Queer
Eye for the first time?
- I felt seen, you know,
especially seeing somebody
like Tan, who was in the
industry that I wanted to be in.
I felt like all those people
my whole life that told me
I wouldn't amount to anything
that I would never find love
that I would never be in
a normal relationship.
I would never live a normal life.
The five of them proved that you could.
- I felt a deep, I have to say it.
I felt a deep tingling
in my loins for Kyan.
- Oh God, yes.
- Yeah, he really-
- Oh yeah, I had a huge crush on Kyan.
- Oh my god.
- [Interviewer] I worry
that the people we help
will fall back into their old lifestyles.
Three, two, one, go.
- I disagree, because even if they go back
to their own lifestyles,
I like to think that
they had a nice little experience
and a moment in time they can go back to
whenever they're ready and
they have that willingness.
- Listen, if you've chosen
to disregard everything
we've said more fool you.
- I kind of agree that I
worry about it sometimes.
- I think for my category, it's harder
because they're not just
gonna throw out everything
I gave them.
- I don't know.
(all laugh)
- Well sometimes they have!
- [Interviewer] Okay, this
section is called Hot Takes
and we had our audience submit prompts
that they want to ask you guys.
- The back of this dress is really pretty,
so I better stay like this for this one.
- I've had a crush on
another Fab Five member.
Three, two, one, go.
- I mean, yeah.
- That's rude.
- That is not true Antoni.
Get over there, get over there right now.
- [Tan] I don't believe you-
- [Jonathan] Get over there.
- You were in love with me
for two seasons, come on.
When I first met Karamo, he knows this,
I had a real crush on Karamo.
- Me too, I really was like,
"Oh my god, like just
(beep) split me in half."
That's how I felt.
- I didn't think that,
- Oh.
but I just thought he'd
be nice to make out with.
- I think we all equally found
each other very attractive
in the beginning but then we all became
like brothers and friends
and it, that never happened.
But of course in the beginning,
I think, yeah I was
attracted to everybody.
- I genuinely love all
of you, but I've never,
I know what a crush is like
and it doesn't equate to that.
- I strongly disagree with him.
(Bobby laughs)
That's what I strongly disagree with.
I'm about to take this
"strongly disagree" cone
and put it up where the sun doesn't shine
because it's not true.
- [Interviewer] I have the
hardest job on the show.
Three, two, one, go.
- We'll just all go over here.
(Antoni laughs)
- Wow, I'm so shocked.
(Bobby laughing)
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- [Antoni] This, this is it.
- Absolutely.
- This is it.
- This is what teamwork looks like.
- Yes.
- And then there's you two.
- Even though Bobby has to
like build an entire house
and everything, I feel like
doing hair is really hard
and sometimes people are
really upset about it.
And sometimes I have to like
do haircuts on people who have no hair.
And that's really hard.
- I think I have the most time
consuming job on our show.
I wouldn't say, I wouldn't
say it's the hardest.
- Time consuming is, I'm just kidding.
- Because there's been episodes,
where Tan's had the hardest
where Antoni's had the
hardest, when Jonathan,
we've all, our jobs have all
been hard in different ways.
- Karamo's never had, oh no, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, no.
He's definitely had some
that have been hard to crack.
Would we agree with that?
- I was at the salon 12 hours one time.
- Girl, it takes me weeks to do episodes.
- Schmeeks, weeks.
- I would argue that a bolognese
can take three to four hours.
(Bobby laughs)
- [Interviewer] There were heroes
who were tough to work with.
Three, two, one, go.
(Bobby laughing)
- You idiot.
Yeah, there's been a lot
of 'em that are hard.
I mean, our show is an emotional show.
There's a lot of times people don't want
to really go through the process
and it it's hard sometimes to,
I know Tan's definitely
struggled with that.
- Willingness is not binary,
it's not black and white.
It's not yes or no.
It comes in all the
different shapes and forms
and we love all our heroes equally.
Can some of them be a
pain in the ass at times?
Yeah! But do we give up, no!
- [Interviewer] Pronouns
should be on all name tags.
Three, two, one, go.
- Yeah
- Tricky one.
I have a question before
I make a decision,
what if the person hasn't
figured out their pronouns yet
and they're uncomfortable
and it's not something
that they feel comfortable
assigning themselves to a label?
- You know the quickest way to
make those people comfortable
make it mandatory for everybody.
- No, but if somebody's on
their journey, it takes-
- What if somebody hasn't figured it out?
- If it was the norm, if it was the norm
for everyone to just have it.
- I feel like that, I
feel, actually I'm gonna,
I feel like making
someone label themselves
is what society's already trying to do.
(in southern accent) Are
you a man? Are you a woman?
And you need to be.
(in normal voice)
I feel like making
somebody label themselves
before they're ready
is counter productive.
- I'm so torn on this one,
'cause I can honestly stand
at either end of this,
and I feel strongly about both.
- I think that we need
to afford people time
to really figure out who they
are, who they want to be,
how they represent
themselves to the world.
- The thought of having to identify
with a pronoun being
such a terrifying thing,
goes to show how much we should dismantle
the binary in the first place.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause like that's part of
why I identify with he/she/they,
because I don't feel
that I've ever fit within
the binary at all, so that's why
I feel really fluid to like
flip between all of them.
I'm personally really
tired of being misgendered.
And I think other people
that live outside of
the gender binary are sick of it.
So it's like, if you just
had it out there, it's like
it just makes it easier for people
to like navigate something.
- If they said, look,
there are no more he, she.
There's only they, I
could subscribe to that.
But I think if they are
forced to figure out a label,
then I think we're forcing people to
do something that they may
not feel comfortable with.
- Like it's forcing somebody to have
a very public journey before
they may be ready for it.
- And part of why I'm torn,
maybe I might have like an
internal confusion that's going
on right now with sexual-
- But-
- Hold on, one sec, with
sexuality and gender.
'Cause for me sexuality,
like if I came out as gay
and I felt like I couldn't take it back,
but maybe to your point,
it's different with gender.
I just can't relate to it.
- [Interviewer] Gender isn't important.
Three, two, one, go.
- Wait?
What?
Maybe I misunderstood that.
'Cause to me, like when I
think of "is gender important"?
No, it's not, not in a way
that it's not important
to think about.
For someone's journey,
gender is important,
but like someone's definition
of gender isn't necessarily.
- For some people, gender
is incredibly important
to them and that helps
dictate who they are
and who they get to be,
and how they get to feel most comfortable.
- I think there's been too
much emphasis put on gender,
especially by commercialism
of blue is for boys,
pink is for girls and this
is what defines gender.
I think there's been
too much defining gender
and I think that gender should be fluid
in whatever you feel
inside, which is why to me,
I don't feel it's important.
- But because for some
people it is important,
we have to respect that, and
therefore it is important.
As a globe of humans.
Does that make sense?
- Yes, I strongly believe
that it's very important,
because of all the violence against women
and the violence against trans people
and the violence it's like, so for me,
I feel like it's very important
because until we can dismantle
this oppressive, murderous gender binary
that we are living with, I feel like I-
- But Bobby's idea is the goal.
- [Jonathan] It's the goal.
- Yeah, to me I think of it as a goal,
that no, it's not important.
- That's what I'm saying,
I understand the intention.
- [Jonathan] I love your
intention. I think it's great.
- [Interviewer] I had a hard
time accepting my sexuality.
- Did you say had?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- Oh.
- [Interviewer] Three, two, one, go.
- I'm from a very conservative
community as you all know.
And so, I had time reconciling
how it was gonna play out
in my future,
and so I always knew I was
gay, I just didn't know if
it was something I was
ever going to be able
to action without being possibly killed.
And so, so yeah, it was hard.
It was a hard time reconciling it,
but I always knew I was gay.
- Internally, I feel like I knew who I was
and I felt like I knew what my truth was.
I felt like the outside world had like
a bigger problem with it.
- I struggled with it, I think.
A little like post-puberty,
when I realized
that I was attracted to boys and girls,
honestly though, even
just before Queer Eye,
I had a lot of people in my
life who just assumed that
I was straight.
Landing that job and having my life change
and all of the jobs and
everything gave me this
like confidence that I didn't have before.
- [Interviewer] Queer
representation in media
has become way better.
Three, two, one, go.
- Yeah.
- The fact that I'm allowed on TV
and I don't mean allowed as in
somebody gave me permission,
but the fact that there's
somebody like me on TV,
blows my mind. I never
thought in my lifetime
a Muslim, queer, brown
person would be on TV.
- With perfect hair.
- With gorgeous hair.
(all laugh)
- Yeah, when I was little the only person
that was out was Ellen,
and obviously that didn't
end well for her then.
And then Will and Grace, that
wasn't even when I was little,
that was still like early twenties.
And I still think there's
a lot of broadcast shows
that there's zero representation
in and there won't be
because that demographic
won't be okay with it.
- It still makes headlines
whenever there's like
a queer story that's at the
forefront of the leading people.
Whether it's people of
color, anybody queer,
it still makes like a big splash,
and it's like treated
as it's like a big deal,
so it's not normalized yet.
- There are still movies being banned
in Middle Eastern countries.
- Even just like here,
we have like so many,
you know, state legislatures
that are trying to ban books,
'cause they're silly,
silly, silly sillies.
- [Interviewer] We are
truly making a difference
in the world.
Three, two, one, go
- Getting picked up from my house,
on the way to the
airport yesterday morning
a 70-year-old white man driver pulls up,
and I get in the car and
he looks at me and he goes,
"I just have to say your show
has changed my family's life.
My daughter's 27 and she is transitioning
and we couldn't relate,
we couldn't understand.
And we watched your show,
and it allows us to be able
to understand our daughter
and what she is going through,
and you guys have helped my family heal
and be there for our
daughter when there's no way
we could have before."
Moments like that really
make me proud of what we do,
and make anything that, you
know, hot days, this and that.
- [Antoni] Yeah.
- Make it all worth it.
- [Jonathan] Cause the reason
that I stopped on "somewhat",
is I was like, oh, but
there's always more.
We could always be doing more.
We could always be making more progress.
But I feel like what we're all doing,
what we're all bringing.
I do feel like we are
changing the perceptions
and I do feel like we're
making a difference.
And I feel really strongly about that.
- Out of all the human
interactions that we've had,
and it's like, yes, I get very overwhelmed
when people stop me.
But like it never gets old when you see
like multiple generations
of families stop you
at an airport and be like, this
is a show that we can watch
as a family.
I never thought I was gonna
be part of that narrative.
I'm still shocked by it.
- I know it may seem arrogant to suggest
that the work that we're
doing impacts the world
and makes a difference.
However, having kids from
Pakistan message to say,
"I never believed there
was a future for me.
I thought maybe that by
the time I hit my twenties
which is when we're meant to get married,
I'd have to kill my self."
To know that you are out there.
You've got a partner.
You've now got a child
you've lived a life that you
that was normal for you
and your country is in a place that
I dream our country will be
that kind of inspiration.
I, it is priceless.
I don't think that any
of us can really quantify
what impact we make on the
kids in villages in Pakistan,
who've never, ever, ever believed
that they have a life past 20.
That blows my mind.
That's changing the world.
(all cheering)
- Come on, come here, Jackie.
(indistinct talking)
- Karamo, we're thinking,
I don't know why I looked up.
Karamo, we're thinking about you.
- Gone too soon.
- Do you wanna make it clear?
Karamo's just not feeling very well.
He's back, we are still the Fab Five.
(all cheering)
- Watch the lights!
- Whoops.
I said "ow", but it didn't hurt.
- [All] Thank you.
- [Jonathan] Thanks, everyone.